Seth Green is barely in his 40s, but he's
been entertaining audiences for more than
30 years.
He started as a child actor in the '80s, with
work on TV shows like Tales from the Darkside
and The Facts of Life, along with movies like
Can't Buy Me Love and Woody Allen's Radio
Days.
But he truly became a star in the '90s, appearing
in classics like Buffy the Vampire Slayer,
the Austin Powers movies,
"But…"
"Shh"
"I'm…"
"All I'm sayin…"
"Shh"
and Family Guy, providing the voice of true
idiot Chris Griffin.
In the late '90s and early 2000s, it seemed
like Green was in every cool thing that came
out…but he seems to be missing in action
lately.
Here's what he's been up to in recent years.
"This is gonna be awesome!"
Robot Chicken
Stop-motion animation is extremely grueling,
time-intensive work.
But it's a labor of love for Green, who's
been churning out episodes of Robot Chicken
on Adult Swim for more than a decade.
He writes, produces, directs, animates, and
voice-acts on the show, for which he's won
two Emmy Awards.
It's basically a sketch comedy show for and
by nerds, making fun of movies, TV, superheroes,
comics, and cartoons via very short stop-motion
and claymation sketches.
Green has also spearheaded a few specially
themed episodes, targeting things like DC
Comics villains and Star Wars.
"You… don't want to get caught in one…"
"Small claims court?"
"No!"
"Ahh!
What was it?"
In 2016, the show won the award for Outstanding
Short Form Animated Program for its 2015 Christmas
special, beating juggernauts such as Adventure
Time, SpongeBob SquarePants, and Steven Universe.
So if you're wondering why you haven't seen
Green on camera, it's because he's been spending
a lot of time playing with toys.
Voice over work
While a lot of actors supplement their careers
with voice work, or fall back on it when offers
for onscreen roles aren't as plentiful, Green
has always done a ton of voice acting — starting
when he was a teenager, on the syndicated
cartoon "The Comic Strip" segment - entitled
Karate Kat.
He of course has lent his vocal chops to hundreds
of characters on his show Robot Chicken, from
original characters to celebrity impressions.
Of course, his voice has also appeared in
more than 200 episodes of Family Guy since
1999.
He's got an impressive vocal résumé, in
other words, and he's highly sought after.
Green provided the voice of Rocket Raccoon
for episodes of both Avengers Assemble and
Hulk and the Agents of S.M.A.S.H.
And that memorable Howard the Duck cameo in
the post-credits sequence of Guardians of
the Galaxy?
"Why do you let it lick you like that for?
Gross."
That was Seth Green.
He can also be heard as Leonardo in Nickelodeon's
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles reboot.
Basically, he’s a king of cartoons.
Secret Star Wars series
There's an unaired Star Wars TV series that
already has more than three dozen episodes
produced.
Called Star Wars: Detours, it's an animated
comedy set in the Star Wars universe.
Producers wisely signed up Green, who's both
a notable voice actor and, as the many Star
Wars sketches on Robot Chicken prove, a huge
fan.
The problem with Detours?
Disney.
According to Green, there are "39 finished
episodes and around 62 finished scripts."
But it was made before Disney bought LucasFilm
and decided to make more Star Wars movies.
Green, who plays none other than Obi-Wan Kenobi
in the series, says it's "on hold," but that
it might actually likely come out now that
a couple new Star Wars movies have been released.
Bombed sitcom
Meanwhile, Green doesn't always hide behind
clay, action figures, and comic book characters.
He attempted to return to regular live-action
acting work in 2013, starring on Fox's three-camera
sitcom Dads.
Created by two writers from one of Green's
other shows, Family Guy, and produced by Family
Guy creator Seth MacFarlane, Dads was largely
loathed by critics.
The series, about two friends who run a video
game company and take in their elderly fathers,
was called a "racist, sexist, unfunny disgrace"
by BuzzFeed, and "the worst new comedy of
the fall" by E! Online.
Audiences stayed away, too — it finished
the 2013-14 season at #111 in the ratings.
It performed so poorly that Fox cut back its
initial order of 22 episodes to 19…before
canceling it entirely.
Cartoon creator
In addition to controlling the Robot Chicken
universe, Green has his hands in multiple
cartoons.
Since Green is a big pro wrestling fan — he
even once hosted the Slammy Awards — WWE
chairman Vince McMahon approached Green when
he had an idea for an animated show: Camp
WWE.
It's set at a summer camp, where McMahon is
the director and WWE stars past and present
are counselors and campers alike — except
they're, like, little kids.
Green created and produces the show and some
of the Wrestler Babies are portrayed by the
wrestlers themselves, including Sgt.
Slaughter and Ric Flair.
When he’s not producing for WWE, he's an
executive producer on SuperMansion.
It’s a show about a once-mighty superhero
collective whose members are getting old and
their powers aren’t quite what they used
to be.
Appearing on Crackle, it features the amazing
voice talent of Bryan Cranston and Keegan-Michael
Key.
Wedding bells
In 2007, Green was signing autographs for
an event at Golden Apple Comics in Los Angeles
while Clare Grant, a filmmaker and actress
who's also part of the web video collective
Team Unicorn, was there to take photographs.
They met again at Comic-Con and realized how
much they had in common — they liked the
same geeky TV shows, comic books, and toys,
and put in the same elaborate order at In-N-Out
Burger.
Green says they really fell in love during
a two-week Robot Chicken touring roadshow.
They had their wedding in May 2010 and their
reception was decked out with action figures
for every guest to take home.
Ah, what sweet nerd love.
What's next for Seth Green
Green seems to be content, and rightfully
so, with cranking out Robot Chicken and Family
Guy episodes until somebody tells him to stop.
Plus, he still surprises TV viewers by getting
out in front of the camera on occasion.
He's also been cast in the highly anticipated
movie, A Futile & Stupid Gesture, the story
of Doug Kenney, co-founder of the highly influential
National Lampoon magazine in the '70s and
the generation of comedy stars it created.
Looks like Green only accepts the coolest
projects of the decade.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love too!